Do you need information
about how to go to court
or how to find a lawyer
in one of the 27 Member States of the EU?
Or are you a lawyer, a notary or a judge
and need to get in contact with colleagues around Europe?
The e-Justice Portal is the answer for your need.
Go to e-justice.europa.eu
and choose the portal in your own language.
In the menu on the left side of the portal
you have the entrance to an unlimited amount of information.
For legal practitioners the portal
has information on case law.
It tells you how to serve judicial documents
and helps you with tools
for dealing with cross border cases.
such as videoconferencing.
Find out how the judicial system works in Estonia
or how to bring a case to court in Austria.
If you need to get a divorce
or have questions regarding custody,
consult the family matters section.
Have you been a victim of a crime?
The e-Justice Portal offers you information about
how to apply for a compensation.
The e-Justice Portal also has
information about what to do
if you have received an inheritance
from another member state,
0:01:02.500,0:00:07.000
or if you want to resolve a dispute
by mediation instead of going to court.
The e-Justice Portal is the easiest way
to find information
about both the different national legal systems
and also about cross border justice.
We are constantly improving our site so you can
access the information you want as easily as possible.
Go to our website and try us out.